I'm Jared Allen and this is dissected to
play so I definitely remember this you
know it looks a viewers point it's like
oh wow that's a nice block he must be
ready I was panicking yeah because he
got the office of rebound I was I didn't
want my coach to yell at me some way oh
I got to do something so I got the block
just to make up for it I just remember
them yelling stuff at me my teammates
video is the biggest hype man I remember
this one because after this is all over
social media and it's starting to get
annoying because it's like I'm trying to
look at other stuff and this just keeps
popping up in my feet it's just like
people from high school you know random
people or putting me in their mentions
on Instagram it's like you know the red
bubble with numbers and it's like 13 15
you know it's just like I'm over this
over this so another one that kept
blowing up but this one was a little
different you know I read this play from
the beginnings like I know Yanis he's an
amazing athlete I know he can go off
with either foot and just looking at the
Euro stuff and how he was gonna do it I
knew he was gonna try to dunk me with
his left hand I had the advantage I had
my right hand ready for him I'm not a
trash talker you know I blocked this
shot I'll give it to him I'm not trying
to make him anger he is he was the MVP
this year you know some would give him
his respective it gives me my respect
and we go on this was another panic play
because he drove right by me it was like
come on you got to be a better defender
against that like I know it's changed
hardened but still coach has high
standards so at the end of the day I had
to make up ground and went up the block
a shot my goal is to always block the
shot like my goal is always try to block
the shot
I know probably once we both jump in the
air if I can block it I remember nothing
is Ronde but he blew right by Ronde and
I remember him coming straight down the
lane towards me that's like I got
crap--what do i do moment but that's my
job I'm a shot blocker and I I went up
and I got my hand on it he didn't say
anything to me but I heard on social
media he says he wasn't warmed up yet so
okay if that's it then so be it
[Music]